how air pollution threatens natural pest
control methods in sustainable farming
few individuals are aware of the dangers
that air pollution poses to both people
and the environment
humans who breathe polluted air are more
likely to get cancer heart disease and
even birth defects
Additionally the disruption of the
natural ecosystem caused by air
pollution from different human
activities such as industrial
manufacturing car emissions and power
plants reduces biodiversity by altering
the migratory patterns of plants and
animals and affects wildlife habitats
this could jeopardize Farmers usage of
non-toxic non-GMO natural Pest
management techniques genetically
modified organisms
here is how air pollution endangers
organic pest management techniques used
in sustainable agriculture
air pollution has been recognized as an
increasingly major Hazard to the
environment in recent years for instance
a research reported in the journal
science indicated that both indoor and
outdoor air pollution contribute to up
to 8 million premature deaths annually
both natural and man-made sources such
as car emissions and Industrial Waste
gases directly release pollutants into
the air outside
air pollution's effects on organic
farming
natural Pest Management strategies in
sustainable agriculture are under danger
due to the growing issue of air
pollution
the health of plants is impacted by
higher levels of pollutants including
ozone particulate matter and nitrogen
dioxide because they cause premature
fruit ripening which can reduce yields
and quality
due to decreased pest defenses when
crops are stressed by air pollution they
are also more prone to bug infestation
this may lead to lower crop yields and a
higher need for insecticides
the danger of organic pest control
techniques
one of the most environmentally friendly
ways to care for crops is through
natural pest control methods
however a recent study indicates that
the pollution from factories farms and
Autos may be endangering these organic
Pest Management strategies
researchers discovered that ladybugs
struggled to locate their meal when
there is a lot of air pollution around
additionally it prevents them from
having offspring
a healthy environment depends on
ladybugs which also help keep insect
populations in checked and potentially
safe Farmers a lot of money on
pesticides
future of sustainable agriculture
sustainable farming is gaining
popularity as a means of feeding a
rising population well while preserving
the environment
the use of natural Pest management
techniques such as crop rotation or
chemical free fertilizers as opposed to
pesticides is one of the main benefits
of sustainable farming
Recent research has revealed that air
pollution may be endangering these
organic pest management techniques
please subscribe to enjoy more videos
thank you
[Music]